I've got a car on fire we've got a dude
being arrested we have you made it into
the show yet
Carmichael you better make this with the
best blogs ever
the time you leave for the airport when
you arrive at your hotel in Vegas the
same amount of time is just getting
their car and driving to Vegas so this
year we're gonna drive for a third
Sampson and I might drive a little bit
exact but you know if you think if you
think about okay so you got a 45 man
how's my sky from Thunder Studios has
been hitting us up he says we're gonna
get super cheap rates if we shoot there
and they've got all these awesome sound
stages we're really busy today and we're
gonna go down there and find out and if
they don't have cool stages and he
doesn't want to offer us really good
rates to shoot there well then sir I've
wasted my time time to show you guys all
the coolest camera tech tech camera
check their camera check check really
really likes we didn't pass the smog
test
few big out here before blows up she
designed like any like fire trucks here
yet it's just a dude just like hands on
his head killing all man
that's cuz there's another car accident
that there the fire truck set flanking
mile back I talked to the guy who's
responsible to deliver me the statement
of work and when I emailed him and I
asked him he goes oh let me stop me
check in on that but he is the guy who
sends it so he checks in with himself
I'm not I'm not now board might not
happen now it is literally three days in
between today and the day that we're
supposed to be shooting this and he
hasn't sent me the s o W yet so I told
him if he doesn't get it to us today
we're dropping the project just gone to
the hotel or the Encore let's try that
what is this this is a hotel room love
this this is the nicest hotel room I've
ever been in in my entire life
this windows gold I can't see out of it
so swanky this bathroom is bigger than
my kitchen it's currently nine thirty
three percent at 10:30 and we wouldn't
pick of our badges Sam got his just fine
and I don't exist in the system here we
are
got a security checkpoint close that
class class class hi
it's I'm Jake and this is Carmichael all
the gun to twistmas no hide your hand
yeah thanks for having us down this is
Carmichael Eichmann sweet nice oh yeah
um see not yeah yeah dude that guy's
recipe jaywalking that'll teach him to
jaywalk yeah
Crisco he literally could have just been
like I'm sorry and then it would been
fine then but now he's going to jail for
some reason on my badge it says I am the
co-founder and creative director for
Adobe Systems I have no idea why it says
that but I think I'm gonna try and use
this to my advantage today
hey guys Ren's here hey that's the new
inspire
camera rig of the future right here with
the fault you have your focus and a
method so it's stabilized to pull focus
in your hand and shooting in RAW it's
all right there that's so killer this is
the best
see any burning cars or people getting
arrested no I missed out very unlucky to
do the Blackmagic Ursa mini he's finally
out hello everybody my name is Sam I'm
Nicola we comprise two of the directors
on the corridor digital YouTube channel
that's our presentation we got 5,000
likes on our nerf team fortress BTS so
you guys are going to be getting a VFX
breakdown courtesy of R and look how
happy is you guys made me so happy
get off the grass Rin better go girl
you
hey what's up Andrew Kramer here with
another very exciting tutorial huh I
don't want to get rested huh